dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I hear to all of
you fellow scholars out there who are
yearning for some more deep learning
action like I do here goes the second
package buckle up amazing applications
await you as always
links to every one of these works are
available in the description box
this convolutional neural network can
learn how to colorize by looking at the
same images both in color and black and
white the first image is the black and
white input the second is how the
algorithm colorized it and the third is
how the image originally looked like in
color insanity
recurrent neural networks are able to
learn and produce sequences of data and
they are getting better and better at
music generation nowadays people are
experimenting with human aided music
generation with pretty amazing results
sony has also been working on such a
solution with spectacular results
one can also run a network on a large
database of leaked human passwords and
try to crack new accounts building on
that knowledge deep neural networks take
a substantial amount of time to train
and the final content of each of the
neurons have to be stored which takes a
lot of space new techniques are being
explored to compress the information
content of these networks there is
another application where endangered
whale species are recognized by
convolutional neural networks some of
them have a worldwide population of less
than 500 and this is where machine
learning steps in to try to save them
awesome YouTube has a huge database full
of information on what kind of video
thumbnails are the ones that people end
up clicking on they use deep learning to
automatically find and suggest the most
appealing images for your videos there
is also this crazy application where a
network was trained on a huge data set
with images of celebrities a low-quality
image is given where the algorithm
creates a higher resolution version
building on this knowledge the leftmost
images are the true high resolution
images the second one is the grainy low
resolution input and the third is the
neural networks attempt to reconstruct
the original
this application takes your handwriting
of a number and visualizes how a
convolutional neural network understands
and classifies it
apparently george RR martin is late with
writing the next book of game of thrones
but luckily we have recurrent neural
networks that can generate text in his
style an infinite amount so beware
George winter is coming
I mean the machines are coming it is
truly amazing what these techniques are
capable of and as machine learning is a
remarkably fast-moving field new
applications pop up pretty much every
day I am quite enthused to do at least
one more batch of these of course
provided that you like this one let me
know thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time